like Wolfgang say lies in the salt
scammer good region near salzburg on the
northern edge of the alps it's a popular
vacation paradise with plenty of things
to do but it's also ideal for anyone
looking for some tranquil relaxation
Lake Wolfgang's a is 11 kilometers long
it shores are dotted with small towns
that are popular destinations for the
tour boats like sankt Gilligan yeah
gibbehhhhh's soon there are beautiful
lakes and mountains here and it's not
far from Salzburg I wanted to bring my
mother and father-in-law here to enjoy
the peace and quiet that's vacation with
no stress war love this is kind of guys
well hottie of a cliff and you've got a
great range of activities here from
bicycling to mountain climbing to hiking
to swimming you could even go
waterskiing shrimp on my fitness of golf
ball-sized she fought
don't forget wakeboarding with more than
70 lakes the Salzkammergut attracts lots
of water sports enthusiasts Thomas grab
no runs a waterskiing school on the lake
he also offers tourists on a hovercraft
some parts of the lake are more than a
hundred meters deep this patil a member
what's special about lake volf gang z is
its unique water quality the men so if
you take a tumble and get a mouthful of
water no problem it's wholesome and
refreshing Doris who are interested in
history can visit the imperial villa in
ba tichel it was once the summer
residence of the austro-hungarian
Empress Elisabeth known as CC some of
the rooms are open to visitors from
april to october the Empress's study has
remained unchanged since her death to
this day the Habsburg family still owns
the villa and it's a private family
residence the town of house dot on the
lake of the same name has 800 citizens
it was declared a unesco world cultural
heritage site in 1997
salt is still extracted here in one of
the world's oldest mines it's sold to
people living in the region besides come
aboard why I results come a good was
like a state within the state you
couldn't just come here you had to apply
for a visa at the Salt Authority office
in London ah dickenson diet all the
taxes from salt production and trade
which the imperial court the hoff camera
or court chamber that's where the name
salt scam a good comes from that's come
a good today the Salzkammergut is a
popular tourist destination with more
than a million guests every year
you